everybody is Charlie hopefully you've
had a chance to see the légion finale
you requested a video so I'm going to
explain everything that's going on if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC videos every week leave all your
requests in the comments below but I
know there are a lot of floating eye
questions that you guys have after the
finale there's a lot of season two
things that they talked about how season
1 is more of an internal battle David
versus himself a lot of the Shadow King
season 2 is going to be more of an
external battle so that's the beauty of
the shadow king leaving his body is that
there's actually somebody else that he
can reach out and fight it was an
absolutely fantastic series it took a
little while to get going which is why I
think traditional Marvel fans had
trouble finding it orally sticking
around to the last three episodes or so
when it really got crazy and they
started to do actual comic book stuff
but let's go through the episode in
chronological order because there's some
important stuff for season 2 especially
the interrogator character the whole
intro it was this beautiful backstory
about what happened to him in the wake
of David's breakout it humanizes him
because at the end of the episode they
say we need to work together and he sort
of agrees I'll try to convince the other
division people we also learned that
there are two other divisions that we
haven't seen yet we get a teaser for
that through the interrogators husband
who is working with these generals they
say release the equalizer release the
peacemaker so that's like another group
of this big division governmental
organization he throws that in their
face do you understand how big we are
he's part of division 3 they're all
about studying David trying to learn
more about him assess his threat but the
other divisions might have different
goals and different views about mutants
so even if the interrogator has come
around and recognizes that the Shadow
King is the true villain the other
division people might not care about
that they might just be worried about
David who is the world breaker
Hulk name-drop I totally love it when
they said that she wasn't really talking
about the Hulk but if you're not
familiar with world breaker Hulk that's
probably one of the best runs of Hulk
comics ever
it starts with Planet Hulk which were
going to be seeing during Thor Ragnarok
it ends with world war hulk when he
comes back to earth to break everyone
that
I'm into space the Illuminati ganged up
said that he was too much of a threat
the only way we can solve this is by
shooting you into deep space his
spacecraft crashed on Sekar that's where
the Planet Hulk story picks up you can
let me know in the comments if you
really want me to do a separate Planet
Hulk comic book story explainer because
it's fantastic they're trying to extract
the Shadow King permanently from David
but through the soup explainer I love
the way they use soup as a metaphor when
you chop all the bits up have you ever
tried to unmake soup there implying does
the Shadow King has layered himself
throughout David's memories so that's
why David was walking back through his
older memories seeing the shadow King at
all those separate places that was the
soup he was walking through the soup of
his memories going back to his earliest
memory when they're in this moment here
when he's a child it's implied that this
is when the Shadow King first entered
his mind
that's where Sid comes in she says I'll
make a bargain with you and you can come
out through me because the Shadow King
wants to find another host there's
something that he's looking for that he
talks about during episode 7
sexy tell me about the day David came to
live with you a man brought him yeah I
was four would you remember where is it
where is it he's in that giant Map Room
and that's why at the end of the episode
when he's with Oliver he says where
should we look first somewhere warm
so there's a thing that the shadow king
is looking for it's probably something
that will allow him to exist in the real
world without a host so the whole reason
that he needs one is because his initial
battle with Professor X we saw on the
blackboard drawing he was defeated
inside the astral plane so his body was
destroyed his mind lived on inside the
astral plane and that's what you're
seeing here with this black cloud
floating when it enters Oliver's mind
love the pink floyd-- that they used as
they were going through his memories
dark side of the Moon dark side of
David's mine who is the Shadow King so
metaphorically the way they use music is
great in this series shadow king gets
out uses SIDS power to transfer into
female Kari who has the fighting skills
so uses her abilities to take everyone
down then probably one of the best
moments of the series when they're
running at each other with the Sai
energy just rippling all over them so
that's their psychic energy manifesting
in the physical world they can actually
do that Oliver kind of did it in the
dream state when he was creating that
shield around them but it's just a taste
for how powerful David can be this is
just the beginning so when they call him
the world breaker it goes way beyond
telepathy way beyond telekinesis and way
beyond teleportation those are the three
main abilities that we've seen him
manifest so far but in the comics the
different personalities of his mind can
manifest different powers and he can
manifest people in the physic
world-like he'll conjure someone up in
his mind like the British version of
himself which is funny because he's
British in real life so he's talking to
himself
but he could do that in the real world
if he wanted he was wrong I was sick but
I'm not sick anymore so what do you can
do about I'm going to get my money back
so we might see him manifest some new
powers during season two so as Oliver
slips away looking for whatever it is
the shadow king wants David's able to
track him then get sucked up into this
mysterious floating eye no questions
answered so the post-credits raises more
questions than it answers but a lot of
people are like hey wait a minute is he
be taken to the Mojo verse because in
the animated series mojo was sort of a
funny parody of network executives that
we're trying to drive ratings by making
superheroes battle so he would capture
them and make them fight in an arena
gladiator style so people like wait a
minute is this mojo that's capturing him
I don't think that it's mojo I think
that's the equalizer and he's going to
division they spent so much time setting
up this giant web of government
organisations that goes way beyond
division 3 so they'll probably explain
what they are and what their plans for
David are so you have to imagine that
the interrogator is now no longer their
enemy he's trying to help them out but
within the giant evil organization Hydra
style there are bad people and then
there are really bad people so they
didn't confirm that they're not going to
do any specific comic book storylines
for season 2 they're going to be
developing more of the mythology that
they've already set up so the shadow
king will continue to be the big bill
and Oliver will be the big villain
because the shadow Kings inside him
which i think is fantastic of a bomb I
didn't sail who attaches the prices of
ale and on and behind for the cycle the
blinds was the same information in
Braille all of the birds - the gated
follower of fashion I totally loved
Jemaine Clement he's going to be amazing
he was one of the best things about
season 1 but all these other characters
they're coming back in the really cool
news is it's season 2 will be ten
episodes that's up to from the aid of
season 1 so we're getting more episodes
they didn't say when it's going to
premiere presumably the same time season
1 premiered
so overall I
the creative expression of the series a
giant a it is one of the best-looking
superhero shows on television
somatically the writing was great but
I'll give it like a b-minus I'd say four
they're plotting just because it took so
long to ramp up to that but I think
they'll address some of that into season
two because it took him a while to
establish who David was what his powers
were doing now it's all about fighting
an external force so you'll get more of
those traditional x-men battle
situations so let me know what do you
guys think of this series and big
question for you guys I try to change
the way I edit my videos just a little
bit year to year so I'm trying to use
more video in my videos let me know if
you guys like that more than just the
straight-up slideshow methods that I
used to use last year so what's going to
happen next is is I have some new
infinity war behind the scenes I'll post
that in the morning WonderCon is this
weekend they'll probably be some new
footage to drop hopefully there'll be
some new footage no confirmation on that
so just stay tuned make sure you have
alerts enabled for the channel that's
that little bell there and if there's
any specific x-men related videos you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments and there will be a new
giveaway happening when I post that
Avengers video so that should post early
Saturday morning while you wait for that
click here for a brand new game of
Thrones footage and click here for the
spider-man homecoming trailer thank you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you